con sentimientos de profunda tristeza
solo
la reina mi amada madre lynn spears
fueron una inspiración fue un ejemplo
para mí y para toda mi familia
le debemos a ella y difame tenemos una
deuda muy grande la deuda que toda
probable tiene con su madre por el
afecto y la comprensión y el ejemplo que
nos dio a todos
la reina ellis la reina isabel era una
vida una promesa del destino
la amamos profundamente ella cual vio
con su promesa de servicio de toda la
vida y yo hago la misma promesa
con el dolor
toda mi familia
ese dolor lo alto con tanto de ustedes
en el reino unido y en todos los países
donde ella fue jefe de estado
a lo largo de todo el mundo un profundo
sentimiento de agradecimiento por los
más de 70 años en que mi madre fue reina
de tantas nacionales wilson en 1947
cuando cumplió 25 años
ella prometió en una transmisión
durante la mancomunidad durante el
comunismo
07 y dedicar toda su vida al servicio de
su hardware de sus pueblos eso fue más
que una promesa
fue un compromiso profundo y personal
ella pasó toda su vida hizo sacrificios
por su dedicación y su devoción como
soberana
nunca flaqueará a través de los tiempos
del cambio y de progreso web a través de
los llamados de alegría y celebración y
a través de los tiempos de tristeza y de
pérdida de no life durante su vida de
servicio de arba de nuevo todos vimos
que había un amor profunda de las
tradiciones
y es ser reelecto por el progreso que
nos hizo grandes como nación
admiro la fe la admiración y el respeto
que los miraba
fueron el sello de su reino
y como cualquier miembro de mi familia
cobbe de decirlo
ella combinaba esas cualidades con
calidad de humor y una gran habilidad
para ver siempre lo mejor en cada
persona
brindó homenaje a la memoria
en su vida de servicio
a muchos de nosotros
comparto este sentido de pérdida que
perdida más allá de todo lo imaginable
con todos ustedes
cuando la reina llegó al trono
en el mundo todavía sufría de las
consecuencias y privaciones de la
segunda guerra de libia y todavía hoy
las convenciones de los hijos
vimos como nuestra sociedad se volvió
una sociedad de muchas virtudes y muchas
creencias las instituciones del estado
cambiaron también pero a través de todos
los jóvenes de todos los retos wilders
nuestra nación
y
realmente de todos ellos estoy muy
orgulloso y todo
nuestros valores han permanecido y deben
permanecer constantes
y
la responsabilidad
y tengo también
profundamente enraizado
para compartir
todos
y para mostrar el gran respeto por las
tradiciones
de nuestras historias únicas de mi vida
lo ves tu sistema parlamentario de
gobierno
tú no
todo el tiempo que me resta de vida que
dios hold respetar estos principios en
el corazón mío numeración y donde quiero
que ustedes vivan en el reino unido
buenos reinos y territorios a lo largo
del borde medio para que cualquiera que
sea su educación en valor para que sea
su herencia
prometo servirles a todos ustedes con
respecto a seguridad y amor como lo he
hecho durante toda mi vida
de mi vida por supuesto va a cambiar
cuando asuma esta nueva responder long
ya no será posible para morir dedicarle
tanto tiempo y tanta energía a las obras
caritativas a las que me he volcado con
tanta devoción pero sé que extiende este
trabajo tan importante
a quedar en manos
es un campo es un tiempo de cambio
también cuando
cuento con la ayuda cosa de mi amada
esposa a cambio
de su compromiso con el servicio público
desde que ellas en contra y ahora ella
es la reina consorte
y esto exige de ella un nuevo papel y
una devoción
a los deberes y confirmar esta operación
como ahora
los títulos escoceses que significa
tomar las responsabilidades
bonfatti show tuve durante más de 53
hoy en día web tengo el orgullo de
coronarlo como príncipe de gales
título que lleve con un gran privilegio
mont de muchos muchos años de mi vida
a su lado la nueva princesa
seguirán inspirando nuestras
conversaciones nacionales son round
siempre ayudando a conseguir el centro
al mundo sur para ayudar valor a toda la
gran bretaña los de expresó a harry -
toda mi solidaridad mientras ellos
continúan llevando a los vidas
sino algunas pocas semanas se hace con
todos como naciones como mancomunidad
todos son más y más veloz de la basuras
para no sólo
desearlo también a la madre que descanse
recordemos
y que todos crezcamos y nos fortalezcan
con la luz de su ejemplo en nombre de
toda mi familia sólo puede ofrecer
muchas gracias sinceras gracias por
todas las muestras de condolencia y de
apoyo que nos han llegado
esto va más allá de cualquier palabra
que yo pueda dar para expresar el
agradecimiento y a mi querida madre a mi
amada mamá
ahora que logres a este último viaje
para encontrarte con mi difunto padre
solo quiero decir algo muy simple
gracias gracias por tu amor gracias por
tu devoción a toda nuestra familia y a
la familia de las naciones a la cual se
viste con tanta diligencia durante
tantos años
sin que acuerdos de ángeles
canten en tu descanso para tu descanso